تغييرات في قياده مناطق عسكريه روسيه
مختلفه اعلنتها وزاره الدفاع شملت المناطق
العسكريه المركزيه والجنوبيه والغربيه
والشرقيه لم توضح الوزاره السبب فيما اذا
كان مرتبطا بما تسميه العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا التفسير الاقرب حتى الان هو ما
اعلنته موسكو مطلع العام الحالي عن عزمها
اجراء تغييرات كبيره على قواتها المسلحه
بين عامي 2023
والفين وسته وعشرين
[موسيقى]
اما قياده القوات الروسيه المحاربه في
اوكرانيا فكانت شهدت تغييرات على مدار
العام الاول للحرب الشهر الماضي يعين
الجنرال
وهو قائد الاركان العامه للجيش الروسي
قائدا لما تسميه موسكو العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه وتعيينه جاء بعد ثلاثه اشهر من
تكليف سلفه
بنفس المهمه